this is the first whiskey maker in
London for more than a century
co-founded by London company is part of
a wider trend towards craft brewing in
the UK but it takes three years on a day
for whiskey to become whiskey and this
isn't ready yet so in the meantime the
money comes from another spirit with
more obvious London connections we start
to do a gin that's sort of the super
premium and launched with former Masons
and tell us about the gin because you've
actually taken somebody else's business
plan in a sense haven't you up so what
what actually happened was we were
building the space and we found through
a that we sent was a business prospectus
for another London distillery company
and it was a gentleman called Ralph Dodd
and he yeah he didn't succeed in his
plans when we dug into who he was and
he's responsible for vauxhall bridge and
a lot of other projects around London we
felt he needed a tribute and you named
your G not yeah yeah well he deserved it
the distiller sits alongside a gallery
space and a street kitchen in this old
Victorian dairy which has become a
creative hub in South London as a
start-up it was financed by a wide range
of sources from high net worth
individuals to crowdfunding so what did
it take to stand out in a crowded
crowdfunding space originally was with
those crowdfunding platforms a lot of
people were the one doing due diligence
on the valuation models and we were
being very conservative let's say and
and trying to give a good amount of
equity for investment and I think that's
what was attractive to the people who
came to us the company cares about its
ingredients from traceable organic
Bulgarian juniper to historic barley
varieties from the southwest of England
but it's the honey that gives the gym
its floral flavors each postcode and
London has very specific flavor profiles
urban bees have a lot more diversity and
plans to choose from and what did you
drink your gin with from a parent point
of view white chocolate with cardamon a
flavored white chocolate with cardamom
is incredible the gin we developed to be
both Sybil
taxable and you know we're taking a kind
of whiskey twist on Jim ok it is up
fifty percent so don't be surprised at
fifty percent the fifty percent alcohol
content of Dodds gene is not for the
faint-hearted but with all those organic
ingredients botanicals and honey I
convinced myself it was almost a health
food Wow right it's much that's much
easier to drink than I thought it was
going to be